in this video we're going to talk about
the law of demand which is one of the
core ideas of microeconomics and lucky
for us it's a fairly intuitive idea it
just tells us that if we raise the price
if we raise the price of a product that
will lower the quantity demanded for the
product quantity demanded will go down
and you can imagine the other side of
that if we if we lower the price of a
product that will raise the quantity
demanded the quantity demanded of that
product and the law of demand says this
is just kind of generally what we'll see
in a few videos from now is that there
are some exceptions to this but to make
this little concrete let's think about
the demand for a certain product and one
thing I want to clear here and I'm gonna
take go through great pains to not mess
this up is that when we talk about the
word demand in an economic sense in a
formal economic sense we're not talking
about a quantity we're actually going to
talk all else equal ceteris paribus
ceteris paribus all the relationship
between price and quantity demanded if
we talk about an actual quantity we
should say the quantity demanded so
demand versus quantity quantity demanded
these are two different things and if
it's a little it's a little confusing to
you right now hopefully by the end of
this video the difference between demand
and quantity demanded will become a
little bit clearer and definitely over
the next few videos because in this
video we're gonna focus on how the
quantity demanded changes relative to
price in future videos we'll talk about
how the entire relationship how demand
changes based on different factors but
to make things concrete let's say I'm
about to to to release my science
fiction book is space whatever I don't
know whether the book that I want to
release so I'm gonna release some ebook
I'm going to release some ebook and
we've done some market study or we just
know how the price is or how the demand
is related to price where the price is
related to MIT the demand and we're
gonna show that in a demand schedule
demand schedule which is really just a
table that just shows how the the price
and actually
I just I made my first mistake I just
said how price relates to demand I
should say how price relates to quantity
demanded and how quantity demanded
relates to price so demand schedule a
demand schedule it shows a relationship
between price and quantity demanded all
else equal so let's so we're gonna have
some multiple we're gonna have multiple
scenarios here so this column let me do
my scenarios this column let me put my
price and this column I put my quantity
demanded quantity demanded quantity
demanded
so scenario let's call this scenario a I
could price my book at two dollars I
could price my book at two dollars and
I'll get a ton of people downloading it
at that price so I will get sixty
thousand people download my book at that
price my eBook scenario be I could raise
the price by $2 so it's now four dollars
and then it that kills off a lot of the
demand now the quantity demanded goes
down to 40,000 people downloading it
then I could go to scenario see if I
raised by another two dollars so now I'm
at six dollars now that raised that
lowers the quantity demanded to 230
thousand I'll do a couple more of these
scenario D scenario D I raise another
two dollars so I get to eight dollars
now now the quantity demanded goes down
to 25,000 and I'll do one more of these
let's see what color have I not used yet
I haven't used yellow yet scenario II if
I raise it to ten dollars now the
quantity demanded let's just say is
let's just say it is twenty three
thousand so this relationship between
this this shows the law of demand right
over here and this table that shows how
the quantity demanded relates to price
and vice versa this is what we call a
demand schedule now we can also based on
this demand schedule draw a demand curve
and really we're going to plot these
points and and and draw the curve that
connects them because we don't have to
just these aren't the only scenarios
anything in between as possible we could
charge two dollars in one set for the
book
we could charge 450 for the book and so
that's what the demand curve captures a
little bit better because it's a
continuous curve not just five points so
let's do that let's graph it and this is
one of those conventions of economics
that I am NOT a fan of because people
often talk about people often talk about
changing the price and how the quantity
demanded changes from that and in
traditional and most of math and science
the thing that you're changing you
normally put on the horizontal axis so
my if I was in charge of the convention
of economics
I would I would plot price on the
horizontal axis right over here but the
way it's done typically is that price is
done on the vertical axis and so you are
used to seeing it in kind of a
traditional class environment I'll do
the same so we'll put price in the
vertical axis and we'll put quantity
demanded quantity demanded in the
horizontal in the horizontal axis and
our quantity demanded goes all the way
up to sixty thousand so that's to see
this 10 20 30 40 50 60 so it's 10 this
is in thousand 20 30 40 sorry not 45 40
50 and 60 and this is in thousands this
is in thousands and then the price goes
up to ten dollars from two to ten
dollars so let's say this is 2 4 6 8 and
10 2 4 6 8 and 10 so let's plot the
scenarios so scenario a price is $2
60,000 units are demanded that is
scenario a right over there
scenario B when the price is $4 40,000
units are demanded four dollars 40,000
units and it's right over there that
scenario B scenario C $6 30,000 units $6
30,000 units right over there
scenario C scenario D $8 25,000 units $8
25 is right about there that looks like
25,000 right in between that's close
enough so that right over there is
scenario D Sen air
d and then finally scenario e $10 23
units $10 23,000 units so it might be
something like that that is scenario e
and so we could actually have prices
anywhere in between that and maybe we
could even go further so this right over
here so if I were to draw the demand
curve it could look something like this
the demand curve would look something
I'm trying to do my best to draw it as a
straight continuous line could look
something like that and it could keep
going on and on and so these are two
ways to show demand so just going back
to what I said earlier the quantity
demanded is all else equal for a given
price for a given price how many units
people are willing to download or buy of
my eBook when we talk about when we talk
about the demand itself when we talk
about the demand itself we're talking
about this entire relationship so this
demand itself is this entire demand
schedule or another way to think of it
is this entire demand curve if demand
were to change if that man were to
change we would actually have a
different curve this curve would shift
or the the entries in this table would
shift if the quantity of demand changes
so we move along this curve when you
hold everything else equal and you only
change price so hopefully that makes
that clear when when when everything
else is equal and you're only changing
price you're not changing demand you're
changing the quantity demanded that the
demand because everything else is equal
is this relationship in the next few
videos we'll think about what does
happen when you do change some of those
other factors